[Music]
alright guys let's be honest we have all
at one point or another had a terrible
experience playing ranked online I mean
cheaters Bader's toxic teammates it is
rough out there so grab a stress ball
and pour yourself a stiff drink cuz
today or counting down the top 10 worst
players you can read online starting us
off at number 10 is the player who will
do anything to win the cheater if you
can't figure out these guys are cheating
you don't - no matter what game you're
playing you're gonna run into a cheater
at some point whether they're using wall
hacks or an aimbot or macros or
something else the other kids you know
just get the car and go all the way to
that hood in the front you're gonna get
keep them there outside of put [ __ ]
that's it y'all won there is nothing
more infuriating than losing to a
cheater
but until someone makes an anti cheat
that actually works a hundred percent of
the time we're gonna have to put up with
them a little longer coming in at the
number nine spot is the person that
makes every CS player tilt off the face
of the earth when you encounter them
baiting is what happens when you get
used by another player they trade your
life for their kills
stand right there just bounce all those
no go stand there stand
so you're both turning a corner onto a
site the Baader always makes sure you go
in first so they can easily kill the guy
who's focused on you at the number eight
spot is the guy who ruins your game
before it even starts I hadn't no I'm
playing
caffeine that I told myself I wouldn't
play I'm back picture this you're
loading up to play your favorite game
let's say it's League of Legends and you
hover over your favorite champion but
then as if the other team saw it coming
that champion gets insta band really
banned Raven that's fine
hey Bandra I'd why would you do that
makes no sense
your blood boils all you wanted to do
was play your favorite character in your
favorite game and now all you can do is
be miserable as the enemy team gets to
have a good time at your expense all
because of one ban absolute [ __ ]
[ __ ] but hey at least your champion
didn't get banned by some toxic little
[ __ ] on your team now that is the worst
number 7 on our list is the ghost who
somehow queued for matchmaking we've all
been haunted by this nightmare you queue
up but get into a game and start playing
only to realize that one of your
teammates is just chilling it's fun and
isn't responding to chat is he are these
guys both afk I swear to God alright at
least they have three players but if
these guys are both afk then it's a then
it's a to v3 again like you gotta be
serious bro you're in the first few
minutes of the game and he's still not
moving you're in a teamfight and he's
still not moving you're about to lose
still not moving the world ended still
not moving you go on to the number 6
spot on this list and he's still not
moving
ok no judgement here but sometimes you
get teamed up with a player who isn't
exactly the best but then you realize
your ranks are about the same you should
not be getting matched up with a player
this far below your skill level unless
I'm a boosted animal animal I'm on time
I start it throws 5
boosting is a plague that's infected any
game that's ever had ranked matchmaking
be ogre players will pay people to boost
them to a higher rank so they look
better at the game than they actually
are
I think the soldier bought this account
guys look at what his [ __ ] positioning
did no soldier ever positions there no
matter what yeah he definitely bought
this again the problem is that that
illusion falls off pretty quickly once
they're actually in the game yeah I
don't know man
this is call them a bot or just a
boosted animal the point is you never
want to have one of these players
dragging your team down it looks like
this might be some kind of strange
boosting service coming in at number 5
on our list is the person who's playing
under questionable chemical influences
no I'm not so bird you want you want
place there's always that one guy who
joins the match and make sure the first
thing everyone else hears is I'm so now
honestly this teammate isn't all that
bad obviously still not sober but maybe
that's their secret maybe getting a
little tipsy or stoned is their path to
victory but I ask you is it really worth
it to hear this the entire match yeah I
didn't think so
can't slurp alcohol that [ __ ] hurts
communication is key to success in any
team-based game but why is it that
there's always one dude in your game
who's working their hardest to ruin your
comms a player who never shuts up and is
always toxic nice
[ __ ] you lucky lady when you're dead get
the [ __ ] up no I'm YouTube every time
you're speaking it's an bits and each
only one time in foreigners are okay but
this player contributes nothing to the
game and afterwards whether you've
wandered you've lost you've probably
either raged at this guy yourself or
just muted it yo [ __ ] man I'm so tilted
at least they aren't as bad as the guy
who actively stops you from winning
speaking of which taking the number
three spot on our list is the kind of
player who has mastered the infamous
technique of losing games and tilting
everyone I lose this game for you for
being so we do don't we - you four
people being toxic you lose the games
what same about they are yellow that we
just took of us among the most
despicable people you can get teamed
with are those who throw games just
because they're tilted and they want to
take you down with them they don't care
if you have yellow at stake they don't
care if they're wasting your time all
they care about is running it down and
sitting back while you see than your
chair at the person who is literally
wasting your time let's just straight
down now we go baby
but a long [ __ ] time all you can do
is report the player and hope something
gets done because as of right now no one
seems to have a great solution for how
to deal with these kind of jerks we
switch the junk I'm still going bro
sorry is this gonna be a [ __ ] I don't
care like these dudes down here that's
why should I be this bitching right now
that's all you're doing
I'm meeting you - all right bye
coming into the runner-up spot on our
list is the bane of all streamers the
stream sniper
I don't know what I don't know what we
do how do we combat them knowing
unfortunately there's one class of
player who wants to ruin their day and
make their stream a living hell
I think I've never gotten a stream safe
so hard in my entire life in a solo by
watching the stream the stream sniper
has all the information they need to
hunt down a streamer in the game and
kill them in ways that just aren't fair
watch for the emote watch the emote why
to emote emote emote I know this guy no
oh my god did father like how pity isn't
building I'm gonna be showing you what
an idiot how stupid can you be
but it's not always just about getting
easy kills
sometimes stream snipers are just there
to troll you in any way possible and all
you could do is sit there and take it
while your chat laughs along
[Music]
I'm gonna go taking the top spot on our
list is the absolute worst player to get
teamed with the worst person on the
Internet
the person who insists his garbage Wi-Fi
is good enough for gaming a player with
crap internet could ruin your game in
all kinds of ways if they're on the
other team
you can't hit them because they're
lagging so bad if they're on your team
they miss every shot because their
router was made by fisher-price what the
[ __ ] Shipman but the true worst version
of this criminal is the fighting game
player with bad internet you could be
the best player in the world and you
will still never beat the person on two
kilobytes in our Wi-Fi because their
teleporting all over your screen this
isn't real
this isn't real look guys we understand
that having good internet is a luxury
and it can be expensive but please
please do us a favor and plug in your
Ethernet cable do it not just for
yourself but everyone else you'll ever
play with okay you having some trouble
there with that door the [ __ ] dude come
on it's the pink well that is it for the
top 10 worst players you can meet online
and that list was a tilter now look guys
if you want to meet some players who
aren't so bad online head on over to
twitch.tv slash the score in eSports
give us a follow and turn notifications
on because we go live on the regular
these days oh yeah and if you haven't
subscribed to the YouTube channel yet
what are you waiting for
buttons just just down there it's right
over there alright end of the video
let's continue on with the tour of Colin
set look if you're feeling lost in these
crazy and hectic times these days if
you're feeling like you're living in a
dystopia well I have the author for you
if you've never read William Gibson he's
a pioneer of the cyberpunk sub-genre a
lot of what he wrote in Neuromancer
which is probably still his most famous
book was eight for The Matrix movies and
countless other forms of media he
predicted a ton of different things to
do with the internet and with modern
technology and he was writing you know
in 80's and 90's and he's I believe
still writing today if you're interested
in all the terrible things that
technology can do to our lives and all
of the disturbing dark and dingy
possibilities of our future world I
would say William Gibson is a guy you
should check out